[Musik]
und zum weltfrauentag begrüße ich aus
berlin die journalisten publizisten
bloggerin und engagierte feministin
teresa bücker hallo frau becker
guten morgen also ein weltfrauentag in
corona zeiten wird natürlich zuerst ein
schlaglicht auf die folgen der pandemie
für die gleichberechtigung die
gleichstellung hat coroner die
fortschritte der letzten jahre zur
dichte gemacht die pandemie hat
sicherlich nicht alle fortschritte der
letzten jahre zunichte gemacht aber wir
haben ja in den letzten monaten oder
auch im letzten jahr sehen können dass
die pandemie bestehende problemlagen
geschärft also diskriminierungen
verschärft das trifft nicht nur frauen
das trifft eben auch menschen die in
unteren lohngruppen arbeiten die in den
sogenannten systemrelevanten gruppen
arbeiten
das trifft aber auch eltern und
natürlich mütter besonders aber
eigentlich sehen wir hier nur eine
verlängerung der probleme die schon
vorher existierten und das ist ein umso
deutlicheres signal dass wir in diesen
bereichen sei es kinderbetreuung die
schlecht bezahlten berufen oder eben
auch häusliche gewalt sehr viel
nachzuholen haben und politische
maßnahmen brauchen die diese dinge
effektiv bekämpfen und verbessern
in der bundestagsdebatte am freitag zum
weltfrauentag da hat die cdu abgeordnete
nadine schön gesagt die korona krise die
könne zur chance werden wenn die
richtigen lehren daraus gezogen würden
was wäre denn für sie die richtigen
lehren also es sollte ja nicht erst nach
der pandemie losgehen wir befinden uns
ja schon ein jahr in der pandemie und
jetzt darauf zu warten dass sie
irgendwann vorüber ist und wir wissen ja
nicht wann das sein wird das halte ich
nicht für besonders ambitioniert ich
denke was unter anderem eltern in den
letzten monaten gebraucht hätten wären
deutlich bessere unterstützungsangebote
zum beispiel unbürokratische
möglichkeiten die arbeitszeit zu
reduzieren um eben das homeschooling
oder die betreuung abzufedern
wir sehen deutliche probleme bei der
bekämpfung und bei der verhinderung von
geschlechtsspezifischer gewalt in
deutschland fehlen über 10.000
frauenhaus plätze das heißt gewalt
betroffene frauen
können überhaupt nicht untergebracht
werden sie haben nach dem aufenthalt im
frauenhaus oft probleme auf dem
mietwohnungen zu finden weil die einfach
überteuert sind und das sind ganz
wichtige ansätze wo uns die istanbul
konvention eben auch vorgibt dass
geschlechtsspezifische gewalt verhindert
werden muss
und daneben aber auch da wo sie passiert
bessere unterstützungsangebote da sein
müssten das war vor der pandemie akut
und der müsste eigentlich auch schon
jetzt innerhalb der pandemie sehr viel
mehr geld in die hand genommen werden um
diese menschen eben besser zu schützen
besonders viel verbesserungsbedarf
besteht ja in der arbeitswelt also von
gleicher bezahlung über flexible
arbeitsformen und arbeitszeiten gerade
für mütter sie haben gerade gesagt bis
hin zu teilzeit in führungspositionen
auch das ist bisher kaum zu finden
aber das zu ändern ist das aus ihrer
sicht allein aufgabe der politik oder
wer muss daran mitwirken
die politik muss schon strukturen auch
vorgeben weil wir wissen aus der
forschung zur gleichberechtigung dass
appelle eben nicht reichen die
gleichberechtigung hat immer in den
letzten jahren und jahrzehnten deutlich
vorangebracht wenn politik sachen
geschlossen hat wie zum beispiel das
elterngeld aber auch das recht auf
teilzeit und in diesem bereich bräuchten
wir also maßnahmen die es menschen und
gerade auch paaren mit kindern leichter
machen auf einem ähnlichen niveau zu
arbeiten also ein gutes modell für
gleichberechtigung wäre eben wenn eltern
30 stunden arbeiten können so dass wir
nicht mehr das modell hätten
der partner meistens der mann arbeitet
40 stunden die partnerin er in teilzeit
20 stunden vorüber sicher auch der
gender pay gap ergibt aber auch der
gender pay gap das heißt dass frauen
häufig sehr viel mehr hausarbeit sehr
viel mehr unbezahlte kinderbetreuung
auch übernehmen
und da eine angleichung zu schaffen da
brauchen wir eben auch politische
maßnahmen weil es nur an die unternehmen
zu geben
das wird nicht reichen und das wissen
wir ja auch aus der quote für vorstände
und aufsichtsräte dass die freiwilligen
selbstverpflichtungen die es schon gab
einfach gar nichts bewegt haben und erst
mit gesetzlichen regelung zur quote da
jetzt auch bewegung reinkommt der
stichworte quote das bundeskabinett hat
ja unlängst eine vielbeachtete reform
des gesetzes zur frau
quote in vorständen auf den weg gebracht
also in großen börsennotierten
unternehmen müssen vorstände ab vier
mitgliedern künftig mit mindestens einer
frau besetzt sein
ministerin gipfel spricht von einem
frauenpolitischen meilenstein ist er das
wirklich
die frauenquote hat eine gute
symbolische wirkung ich würde sie nicht
unterschätzen und ich finde sie
eigentlich auch noch zusammen
weil wenn wir eine quote haben von 30
prozent dann heißt das ja dass 70
prozent der plätze eigentlich immer noch
für männer reserviert sind also ich
würde mir schon mit 50 5 50 quote
vorstellen um eben auch die realität ein
bisschen besser abzubilden natürlich
jetzt von der quote in vorständen und
den aufsichtsräten profitieren nur
einige wenige frauen wir brauchen sehr
viel mehr frauen politische und
feministische maßnahmen um wirklich
gleichberechtigung überall zu schaffen
weil es ist ja nicht gesagt dass nur
weil eine frau vorständen in einem
unternehmen wird das reinigungspersonal
auch gut bezahlt wird und das sollte es
natürlich auch das heißt wir brauchen
höhere mindestlöhne die eben auch
armutsfest sind und dann nicht dazu
führen dass menschen die zum beispiel in
großen konzernen die beruf lore reinigen
dann später in altersarmut landen
nochmal zum abschluss etwas andere frage
der verband entwicklungspolitik ruft er
dazu auf auch anlässlich des
weltfrauentages eben nicht mehr an
podien teilzunehmen an
podiumsdiskussionen die ausschließlich
mit männern besetzt sind ich weiß auch
beim privaten umfeld dass das
unternehmen gibt die interne
entsprechende richtlinien ausgeben wo
frauen oder männer die eingeladen sind
im grunde genommen absagen müssen
wenn eben ansonsten nur männer vertreten
sind ist das der richtige weg zu mehr
geschlechtergerechtigkeit
es ist ganz ganz wichtig was eben auch
in der öffentlichkeit abgebildet wird
das betrifft nicht nur männer und frauen
das betrifft zum beispiel auch
ratifizierte menschen also innerhalb des
feminismus ist es zb so dass wenn wir
über arbeitsmarktpolitik diskutieren
oder über gewalt auch sehr darauf achten
sind auch frauen auf color sind frauen
mit behinderung vertreten weil die ja
noch mal von ganz unterschiedlichen
diskriminierungen auch betroffen werden
also da sollten wir alle darauf achten
dass wirklich die vielfalt der menschen
in der öffentlichkeit repräsentiert wird
in den medien ist es auch sehr wichtig
der spiegel hat heute zahlen
veröffentlicht die haben ihre eigene
berichterstattung analysiert und
festgestellt in über 70 prozent der
berichten geht es nur um männer kommen
nur männliche protagonisten vor
und die haben sich jetzt vorgenommen
dass sie ähnlich wie die bbc das
angleichen wollen auf 50 50 und eben wie
die geschlechter in der öffentlichkeit
dargestellt werden auf podien auf
konferenzen in medien ist ein ganz
wichtiger baustein von
gleichberechtigung
da ist noch eine menge luft nach oben
und es bleibt zu hoffen dass der
weltfrauentag heute doch ein besonderes
schlaglicht auf diese jahr
gesamtgesellschaftlichen defizite wirft
frau becker ich danke ihnen für dieses
gespräch und größe ins offenbar sonnige
berlin dankeschön sonntag